It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today, Ruffians, for our 87th episode!
87th!
Right!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, what do you mean you lost count?
Yes, good!
BAU BAU!
Even though it's the 87th episode, there might be some Ruffians who are joining us today for the first time!
So, to explain a little bit about FUWAMOCO Morning, it's a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday, aka FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
And with that, we have bad news.
Huh?
Is it another Pero Sighting?
Why did you see him this time, Ruffians?
Well, let's see.
De-den!
Is this Peron?
I just wanted to take a nap in the street.
That's kind of a crazy spot to find him in.
You can't even see his face!
Right!
You don't expect to see Pero- Oh!
Oh!
That kinda looks like Pero in the middle of the street!
The round... Right.
The round shape though.
That's definitely him.
Definitely him, huh?
I wonder though, do you think... Do you think maybe he got scared and decided to hide in... The worst place possible!
I don't know, maybe he's stuck?
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
This is where he is now.
Kind of like, you know, like a murder hornet that gets stuck in a sticky mouse trap.
Just leave him!
Dig him out!
I don't know... He needs help, you think?
Yeah, he looks like he fits in there, but... Ruffians, you think you should help?
Speed BAU!
Tickle him!
Tickle him...
That was so bad.
No, no, don't help him.
No, okay.
Okay, okay.
That's your answer.
Pero will have to get himself out of this one.
Yeah.
No helping.
Although it'll be kind of interesting to poke him and see what happens, right?
Do you think he'll make a sound?
I'd be scared to run away if that happened.
Give him a poke and then leave.
BAU BAU!
What did he do to you?
He's nasty!
Okay.
He's nasty, so this is normal.
This is regular.
Oh, you can jump on it.
That would be fun.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians!
We're really really excited for
Beginning of May.
I don't know why I'm so excited, but very much for the beginning of May!
Because!
FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be participating in a fan meeting in Taipei!
BAU BAU!
We really want to be able to chat lots and lots and BAU BAU together too.
Thank you so much, BAU BAU!
Thank you for the moments!
We're really excited!
But it's not just a fan meeting though!
We'll be participating in the special hololive meet Super Carol Giveaway performance on May 11th!
And it's not just us!
We're gonna be there along with Kobo-senpai, Bibi-senpai, Aya-senpai,
We're so excited!
We're gonna sing a bunch.
Lots of songs.
We hope that you'll be able to make it.
Maybe you're in the area.
Maybe?
If you are, make sure you're noisy!
And loud!
And crazy!
And BAU BAU BAU BAU!
That's okay!
It'd be nice if you taught us a lot about Taipei, too!
We're just so excited!
It's gonna be fun!
BAU BAU!
I really hope we can meet a lot of Ruffians there.
We know it's pretty soon, huh?
If you're in the area.
BAU BAU!
You know, there's been so many exciting things going on and not just coming up.
But, while we were busy finding our new doghouse, there was some new FUWAMOCO merch that we missed!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, you know, well, maybe Ruffians, do you kind of ever feel a little shy of buying merch of your oshi?
Because, you know,
She's just so cute and maybe it's not quite your style.
Yeah, I know!
Ruffians are rough.
You may be a little bit embarrassing sometimes.
FUWAMOCO the pink and blue.
Pink and blue is not, well, if that's the problem, that's not gonna help.
But it's okay!
It's okay!
You can get FUWAMOCO merch because on hololive official shop.
Now there's emblem style merch.
FUWAMOCO my team!
It's still blue and pink.
But you think blue and pink are embarrassing.
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm not a chihuahua, I'm not a chihuahua, I'm not a chihuahua, I'm not a chihuahua, I'm not a chihuahua.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Please check them out, Ruffians!
Especially if you want to grow your FUWAMOCO merch collection!
Don't be oppressed though, okay?
They're pretty cool!
Design kakkoii!
Kakkoii ne!
Hopefully they'll arrive soon!
Let us know, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Pero merch doko?
Really?
I thought we decided we're gonna leave him in the void.
Do you really want merch of a speed bump?
Yeah.
Oh no.
Why?
My oshi's a speed bump.
Hi!
Wow.
Hair merch, really?
Okay, Ruffians, that's interesting.
BAU BAU!
Oh, well, Ruffians, you know, now FUWAMOCO Morning is back and everything.
But maybe, you know, during your busy day, suddenly you're like, I don't know, something's missing.
And you just get the sudden urge to hear a good BAU BAU!
Maybe?
Maybe not?
Yeah!
Wow!
Now you can hear a good BAU BAU whenever you need to if you head over to FWMCBAUBAU.com!
Yeah!
There's the global BAU BAU counter and if you click on it on FUWAMOCO there, you can hear many different BAU BIAs from us!
BAU BAU!
Have you tried it?
BAU!
You can get a little addicting sometimes, huh?
Yeah.
You know, this means that wherever you are, you can get some more BAU BAU powers!
Get to use their day, you know.
Or even on the phone, too!
Or maybe they helped you out a month ago!
When you're sleepy and your brain is moving a lot, then you can just go BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And then you'll get a bit sleepier.
I hope you'll get sleepier excited.
It's a little very addicting.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
Please go check it out.
Get some BAU BAU power!
It's just so much fun.
And the biggest thank you!
Thank you so much to Artful Peace for all the love and creativity to make this a fun website.
Amazing!
Thank you from the globe for BAUFUN!
BAU BAU!
That is... 2 million!
Ruffians, have you been BAU BAUing at the BAU counter?
BAU BAUing at the BAU... I wonder how many BAU BAUs are your BAU BAUs.
I wonder how many are ours.
Please check it on FWMCMORNING.
Actually, sometimes it's sort of fun.
Because I'll press the BAU BAU counter and then I'll see that it went up again without me.
So I'm BAU BAUing at the same time and Ruffian is also BAU BAUing.
Sorry for the fun.
BAU BAU!
You BAU BAUing right now!
BAU BAUing!
Oh, Moco-chan, should we make a special BAU BAU for the BAU counter?
Right now!
BAU BAUing!
BAU BAU!
I wanted to stand out, you know.
Thank you!
Ruffians!
You know, you might have heard...
During my super chat reading the other day, I might have mentioned something.
I know.
That maybe my chance to get a sign that says, don't feed the dogs.
I know so I don't get as many tweets from the staff.
You know, everyone knows that we love Pondering Donuts.
And so, they kind of keep on appearing whenever we go to the studio, right?
When we met Mine-chan the other day, she had a gift for us!
It wasn't Pondering, but it was something...
Really delicious.
A bunch of coupons for Taiyaki!
To be exact, ten coupons for Taiyaki!
Taiyaki!
We love Taiyaki!
Ten coupons.
Ten.
Yeah, you know, we can't turn down a gift from Mari-chan.
You know, wouldn't you be sad if you tried to give someone a gift, and then they said they couldn't eat it, and then gave it away and tossed it out?
Right.
You need to accept it to spe- Accept the feelings, you know?
Yeah.
You can't just toss it out.
No.
Ten-yaki?
Ten-taiyaki?
Ten-taiyaki.
Thank you, Mori-chan!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, what flavors should we get?
There's the traditional rabbit, but there's also other flavors like custard, sweet potato.
Sometimes there's matcha.
Not so good!
Custard.
Red bean.
Chocolate.
Sweet potato.
Custard.
I don't think I've ever had a custard one.
We have ten taiyaki, we could get a bunch of different flavors.
I feel like we should share them.
Apple mango!
I've never seen that before.
Root beer flavor.
I would.
I don't think they have root beer flavor.
Maybe they have Salonpas flavor.
Salonpas flavor taiyaki!
Salonpas taiyaki!
No.
Maybe we'll take our time.
Maybe one taiyaki here.
Another taiyaki here.
Maybe we should get that sign from Mane-chan no ha.
Maybe.
Thank you guys!
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Ruffians!
It's another FUWAMOCO Morning!
That means there's another Doggie of the Day today!
Who's today's Doggie of the Day?
Today's Doggie of the Day is... The Dog!
It's Freya and Rooney!
I'm going to guess that maybe Freya is the one with the black fur there and the beautiful eyes.
Look at the brown eyes there.
I'm sure there's a second one.
And Rooney is the one there with the very like
What kind of look would you take this in the eye?
Sleepy.
Sleepy?
I'm thinking furious.
Seductive.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU.
Like that.
Like that?
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU BAU.
Yeah.
What about Rooney?
BAU BAU.
I feel like Rooney might have a very deep voice.
But you know, you're so lucky to have Rooney in your life.
Two wonderful pups!
Ruffians!
There's also another two wonderful puppies here too, huh?
Yeah, but three of them, huh?
Hi!
That's fun.
We hope you enjoy the birthday merch, and please make sure that they don't chew on the Ruffian plushies too much.
I think you're into Vtubers.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And for our next corner, I'll get the title, right?
Today, I went for... Today I went on a walk, I even brought it all for you guys!
Where did we go on a walk today, huh?
BAU!
Why?
Maofuji!
Maofuji with G-san!
G-san!
Oh my gosh.
Where did you do it?
So beautiful.
We love Maofuji!
Look, it's so amazing, right?
Whenever we see Mt.
Fuji, no, our breath kinda gets a bit taken away.
I don't know, something about it is just very hot.
That's a mountain.
That's a mountain, Mt.
Fuji!
Thank you for going on such a beautiful walk and taking us with you too!
I don't know, I think it'd be really fun to climb Mt.
Fuji one day.
It's not easy though.
No, and it's busy hot.
I think so, yeah.
It'll be fun, no?
Yeah!
We'll have to try it!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And next, we have our Question of the Day!
My Question of the Day is... De-den!
I'm curious about ponderings, but nowhere near me sells them, so I'm going to try to make my own.
Do you have any favorite flavors or toppings to recommend?
First, good luck making your own!
Please be really careful with, you know, all the hot oil.
And also, go in expecting it not to work out.
They're very hard to make.
You know, even us, we've failed many, many, many times!
So number one thing is just have fun, okay?
But our favorite flavor is just a simple sweet glaze.
Nothing, no flavor really.
It's a flavor.
It's sweet.
It's a sweet flavor.
I don't know.
It's not too thick.
It's just perfectly sweet.
Right.
You know, and they have matcha and strawberry flavors too.
They're nice.
Nice, good.
I think just a simple powdering is the most yummy to us.
Classic.
Yeah.
Especially with a cup of hot milk tea too.
It's perfect.
Yeah.
I don't know, it's not really vanilla.
It's just sweet.
Sweet.
Yeah.
Normal.
BAU BAU!
Good luck!
Maybe I would suggest matcha though.
Especially knowing the kind of pondering FUWAMOCO make.
So you might wanna glaze just in case.
Yeah.
It's not the best.
Just like FUWAMOCO.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
What do you think is gonna happen next round?
Next stream!
I wanna say a big thank you to all the Ruffians for your submissions today for this week.
Because FUWAMOCO Morning, you know, it's a show we make together.
So please continue sending us your submissions with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
You're gonna go on a walk today, right?
Let's take a photo!
Let us see where you went!
Okay!
Or maybe... I know it's scary, okay?
Maybe you're gonna have salad for lunch.
And you're like, ooh, I wonder what FUWAMOCO likes to put in their salad.
What kind of salad dressing.
Do they eat salad?
Let us know with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
And next!
For our next stream,
Wow!
Originally we were going to be having a stream tonight with Ollie-senpai.
We were going to be playing her new visual novel, Days with Ollie.
But unfortunately it's release has been postponed a little bit.
So the stream will be postponed for now too.
It's too bad, but it'll be releasing very soon on the 22nd.
It's not too far off.
So please check it out on Steam once it releases, okay?
So our next stream now is... FUWAMOCO Rock n' Roll Party!
This time we're singing anime songs.
Usually we sing a lot of anime songs.
This time we will sing a lot of anime songs.
I don't know if it's gonna be... Is it gonna be 100% anime songs?
I don't know yet.
I was thinking I want to sing that song.
And that was kind of a... Mostly anime song.
If you like anime songs, you'll like it.
And we can be loud!
And we can have fun!
We haven't heard anything since Donkey Kong, so...
I think we're good.
We might be in the clear.
Please join us on FUWAMOCO!
And like always, it will be archived, so maybe if you're a little busy, you can check it out later, but we hope you'll be there too!
BAU BAU!
And if we take a peek at our schedule, on Sunday at our doggy pack, we're gonna be having a battle plan stream.
You know, it's been 8 months since we debuted.
About 8 months.
FUWAMOCO.
Right.
Strategy.
You know, so we hope you'll be there and be a part of it and let us know if you have good ideas or maybe FUWAMOCO you could try this or you said you wanted to do this but you haven't yet.
You know, let's have a bunch of fun and chat about all those kind of things.
And that's our schedule for this year!
Over!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning and waking up successfully for us!
Successful!
We got to the end of the week and hopefully you're able to wake up, so maybe that means that a new routine, a new habit has formed!
Check!
BAU BAU!
Abyssgard!
Chihuahuan.
BAU BAU!
Alhedo.
Sanpyan.
BAU BAU!
Nobita.
And this one.
BAU BAU!
Final 20.
Warcraft.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!